hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and I
bring you bad news namely that the world
is going to end not the world as in the
earth that we live on but the universe
as a whole is going to come to an end
someday we don't exactly know when and
what I mean by an end it might not be
something as dramatic as literally the
universe ceases to exist but it might
either change so dramatically that life
itself would be impossible or it could
just fade away the universe could end
with a bang or with a whimper so today I
talked to one of the experts in this
slightly depressing area Katie Mac is a
theoretical cosmologist at North
Carolina State University also very
popular science communicator her Twitter
feed is one of the top ones that fellow
physicists follow and we talked about
the different scenarios that sketch out
what might happen to the future of the
universe it's not something that we know
about for sure right making predictions
is hard especially about the future but
we know enough about the laws of physics
to say what the range of possibilities
seems to be either this sort of gently
fading out everything moves apart from
everything else and we just get colder
and slower until the interesting lively
aspects of the universe just fade into
nothingness or it could be something
very dramatic my favorite scenario that
we talked about in this episode is the
bubble of quantum death if you're not
familiar with what that is it'll be
explained to you in grisly detail so
this is both an educational episode in
that we really do get into some real
physics and cosmology but also thought
provoking that science has progressed to
the point where we can actually say
something about what the end of the
universe might be like remember if you
want more info on mindscape you can go
to the podcast homepage at preposterous
universe comm slash podcast where you
can also sign up to support mindscape on
patreon if you want to get Ad free
versions of the episodes and also a
monthly ask me anything episode for all
patreon supporters so with that let's go
[Music]
all right baby Mac welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks it's good fear
we're gonna talk about the universe it's
a big universe out there and I love the
fact that you're writing a book about
the future of the universe yes yeah yeah
specifically the end because there are
so many books about the beginning I felt
like you know we really got to cover the
other side there are and I noticed that
you know when you watch cosmos and they
in the calendar right in the cosmic
calendar yeah the beginning the universe
is on January 1st and the end is
December 31st and we're only alive for a
little bit yeah but I'm like why does
the calendar end yeah a lot longer
yeah definitely yeah I mean it's um yeah
it is interesting like everybody you
know you always get up to today but I
think people just really want to know
about the future you know where it's all
going and stuff like that and and we
just don't talk about that enough as
physicists well I think one thing to get
right is the timescales let's talk about
the kind of the part of the universe we
know the past right because I think that
a lot of people when you talk about the
future yeah the far future they're
thinking like 10 years right yeah so
tell us a little bit about the size and
scope of the universe as we know it now
well so right now our universe is about
13.8 billion years old and we know a lot
about the beginning starting from like a
billionth of a second basically and and
from before that things get a little
murkier about exactly what was going on
but we have a really good map for for
how things have evolved up till now and
we're starting to get a good
understanding of how where things are
going but we've we can map out the
expansion in the universe and we can get
a feel for the size of the observable
universe which is not which is often
used to mean the universe but when we
talk about the observable universe we're
talking about a region that we can see
you know that that we can get
information from and that's pretty big
that's about 46 billion light-years in
radius something like that and that
comes from just the fact that as the
universe has been expanding all this
time there's a certain distance where if
we tried to look farther away from that
the light from that part of the universe
we're trying to look from look at would
take longer than the
to the universe again yeah so we know at
the age when you say the age even there
yeah to be careful right yeah because we
mean the age since the Big Bang
yeah there could have been something
before the big thing sure and and and
the other thing I should mention is that
when people talk about the Big Bang
there's a sort of public understanding
of what the Big Bang is and then there's
the way that physicists usually use it
and those are not always the same so if
you if you talk to somebody on the
street and say what was the Big Bang
people say well it was an explosion
where the universe started as a single
point and then exploded out and you know
that that was the Big Bang and if you
talk to physicists usually what we're
talking about is something really
different called the hot Big Bang where
what's what we're what we're talking
about is just simply the fact that the
universe was hotter and denser and
smaller in the past and and that just
comes from the fact that you know the
universe is expanding now and cooling
and so if we go back in time we can dial
that back and we see that you know the
universe was was cool hotter and denser
and more compressed in some way and that
is completely incontrovertible like that
that like we really did have that that
in that sense the big vein absolutely
happened and we know that because we can
see it we can actually see it directly
because if we look far enough in any
direction the light has taken so long to
get to us that it's coming from the time
when the universe was still completely
on fire
you know the name Erik Lerner a book
called the Big Bang never happened oh
really
yeah okay yeah back in the day even in
my day you know the 1980s 90s when I was
in grad school there was still people
out there who just denied that even the
hot Big Bang model was correct yeah the
plasma cosmology yeah this like the most
important force in the universe is
electromagnetism not grab power and
Sophia yeah amount of stuff amount of
myths that one has to do but okay yeah
the mindscape official position is the
Big Bang happen yeah yeah I mean the ha
yeah the the the fact that the universe
was hotter and denser and some sense
smaller in the past and we can actually
see it and one of the things I think is
kind of neat is you know the TV show The
Big Bang Theory the beginning of the
theme song is actually really
nice encapsulation of the Big Bang
Theory yeah the whole universe was in a
hot dense state nearly 14 billion years
ago expansion started to stop there
that's the Big Bang Theory that's
exactly right I didn't use the word
explode there's a point no singularity
and there may have been a singular like
there it's possible that before that
firey state that you know the universe
was infinitely dense it's possible that
we get back to that point but there's
you know that fiery state was we see the
part that was about 380,000 years after
the beginning in the the 380,000 years a
lot happened and we don't know at the
very beginning of that if there was a
singularity we think probably there was
this rapid expansion inflation and you
know what happened before that super
rapid expansion in the first billionth
of a billionth of a billionth of a
second we don't really know
I'm only 50/50 on inflation myself yeah
yeah I mean that's that's also like yeah
that's I mean it's it's sort of the
standard cosmology but people have
different yeah models of that so you
know but but I should say that like that
really is the inflation if it happened
was 10 to the minus 34 seconds right so
so we're pretty good from 10 to the
minus 34 seconds onward which i think is
an amazing achievement it is certainly
an amazing achievement and but but let's
say give the skeptics some evidence here
so you said that we can only see things
that are past a few hundred thousand
years after the Big Bang but you also
said we have a very good picture of
what's going on a second or less after
so how do you get from here to there
well so there are a few things that we
can do I mean one thing that is that we
can we can look at the the patterns in
that background light from 380,000 years
after and we can learn something about
the matter and energy content of the
universe and the expansion history from
looking at like really carefully
analyzing those patterns another thing
we can do is we we can just extrapolate
that the universe was hotter and denser
and we can do experiments that make hot
dense little bits of matter and energy
and and figure out what physics is doing
in those situations literally here on
earth
yeah so the Large Hadron Collider can
can smash particles together and reach
these really high energies where the
conditions would be very similar to some
of the early universe stuff there are
colliders that could make quark gluon
plasma which is the kind of like
precursor to the particles that we that
we can detect today and that's what we
think the universe was filled with in
this very very early time and so the
fact that we can make a little sample of
a Big Bang universe is kind of cool yeah
so there's that and then there's also
some in some sort of slightly more
indirect evidence from like the
abundance of elements it's called Big
Bang nucleosynthesis so in this early
hot stage there were there was a time
when the whole universe was as hot as
the center of star and so it was it was
fusing elements together and making
helium and lithium and a little bit of
other things out of hydrogen and so we
can we can figure out what the abundance
of those elements should be in the
universe if that were taking place and
it matches really well and so there are
a few things like that where we can we
have a really good understanding of you
know charting out all the steps from
that sort of quark-gluon plasma stage
through the couple hundred thousand
years to the the Cosmic Microwave
Background this background light that we
see and then from there on you know we
have other kinds of observations yeah I
think that it is like you said amazingly
impressive that the human race has been
able to do this like it yeah teasing big
band Big Bang denialists a few seconds
ago but in the 50s who had been
completely sensible to be a big bang
analyst and a hundred years ago there
were no Pro Big Bang people the idea
that he was expanding hadn't been
figured out so all this is the last
century of human progress yeah yeah yeah
I mean I think it's neat that you know
it was during on Stein's career that we
went from an understanding of the
universe's being static to an expanding
one and it really changed the equations
he was using to describe the evolution
of the universe and it totally changed
our understanding of of just how cosmic
history works and where we're going in
the future as well well it's also a
great example the interplay of
observations or experiments versus
theory right so you mentioned Einstein
Einstein didn't go to any telescopes and
collect any of this data but he is the
one who set up the framework that we use
to think about the expansion of the
universe yeah and and you know and of
course he wasn't the first person to
talk about some of these things you know
the matron and the there are a couple
other people who were sort of putting
together this idea of the Big Bang
Theory and and the expansion of the
universe and everything but but you know
there's there's a kind of neat story
behind you know he was writing down
equations that we still use to talk
about the energy and matter continent
universe and he put in an extra term in
these equations to account for the fact
that the universe appeared to be static
threw it out when the expansion started
and now we've been shoving it back in
because we we need it for another
purpose which I can go into that ya know
we don't think you want to go into this
I just want to you know make sure that
the audience appreciates the fact that
general relativity yeah Einstein's
theory of gravity is the way that we
talk about the expansion of the universe
it's not just you know we look at C is
expanding we use Einstein's equations to
run it both forward and backward time
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's it's an
that's another astonishing achievement
because general relativity is like the
most bullet proof theory out there like
we we throw everything we can at this
thing and we've we haven't found a
single I know idea nomally like
everything looks exactly as it should if
general relativity is the law of the
land and never violated which is which
is a little strange because we know that
there has to be somewhere where that
isn't true because quantum mechanics and
general relativity tend not to work well
together so there's got to be something
something's got to give somewhere in
there I mean maybe maybe it's something
about the interplay between common can I
says there's more subtle thing and they
can both be right in their own ways but
it really has been amazing to watch you
know all of these tests of general
relativity everything you can possibly
think of and everything passes
completely it's all looks perfectly
right I mean even you know the the
gravitational waves from from black hole
collisions that Vigo has been seeing you
know there was there was a sort of a
signal similar
with computers using general relativity
like what that signal should look like
if these black holes collide and the
signal comes in it exactly matches it's
like completely perfectly there's no
deviation yeah it exactly matches the
prediction from some equations that
Einstein scribbled down in 1915 yeah
yeah yeah and we're just still like it's
like well that that still works you know
nature yeah yeah probably breaks down
like at the Big Bang the universe we see
yeah
general relativity there you go let me
pause for a second to talk about clip Q
uip electric toothbrushes I remember a
while ago going to the dentist and
asking what kind of dental floss was the
best and I was told
whatever you actually use and the same
thing is true for electric toothbrushes
not just that you have it but that you
use it and how you use it
that's why quip was created by dentist
and product designers to focus on what
actually matters for your oral health
healthier habits using the toothbrush
quip automatically delivers brush heads
to you every three months so you get
clean new bristles all the time it has a
sleek intuitive design that is simple to
use and comes with a travel cap so you
can bring it around with you when you're
traveling the travel cap doubles as a
mirror mount so you can see what you're
doing it's all together a very modern
approach to keeping your teeth in their
best shape good habits matter to live a
healthier life so help form fresh oral
health habits with quip quip starts at
just $25 and you'll get your first
refill free at get quip comm slash
mindscape you can both support the show
and start brushing better by going to GE
tqu IP com / - cape to get your first
refill free get quip comm / mindscape
and so ok you hinted I'll let you you
know tell the punchline to this
particular thing we the universe is
expanding yeah we can map out its
expansion rate you already gave two
hints about what we're gonna talk about
right now because you mentioned
Einstein's stuck this extra term in yeah
but you also said the universe is 13.8
billion years old and over 42 billion
light years across how does this happen
yeah
so so well that that happens because
yeah so you in terms of the size of the
universe I said that the size of the
observable universe is set by how long
it takes light to get from you know the
beginning to us and you know how far
that go and you would imagine that that
should be 13.8 billion light years right
because light travels 1 light year per
year and we've had 13.8 billion years
and so that seems like it should make
sense but but the universe has been
expanding since since the beginning and
so the point that that where light has
taken 13.8 billion years to get to us
has been pushed much farther away now
because the expansion the universe and
the whole history of the expansion and
one thing the fact is into that is the
fact that the current expansion is going
much faster than it seems like it should
be and this is this is something that
that has been a real revolution in
physics since the late 90s where well so
one one big question that sort of
relates to the stuff I'm interested in
right now about the end of the universe
that one may question is how is the
universe gonna evolve in the future ok
we know that it's expanding now is that
expansion gonna keep going forever is
the expansion going to turn around and
then weary collapse and have some kind
of Big Crunch like what what's going on
there and so in the late 90s they were
trying to figure this out and really
what what you need to do to figure that
out is you need to figure out the
balance between the amount of matter in
the universe the amount of like gravity
energy in the universe and how quickly
it's expanding it's sort of the same
physics says if you take a ball and you
throw a ball up into the air if you
throw it faster it'll go higher up
it'll be slowing down the whole time at
some point it'll fall down if you could
throw it at 11.2 kilometers per second
it would reach escape velocity it would
go off into space it would not fall down
but it would always be slowing down a
little bit as it goes because that
initial push is sort of countered by
gravity between the ball and the earth
the whole time so it should always be
slowing down but it might keep going
forever or it might turn around and come
back come back and so we were trying to
figure this out for the universe because
basically the entirely the same physics
applies you know you have this initial
the Big Bang and then then from there of
things expanding but the gravity is
trying to pull it back so we're just
trying to figure out is there enough
gravity that it'll come back so we
wanted to know how how quickly is the
universe slowing down and its expansion
you know what's that deceleration rate
so that we could figure out like is it
enough that it'll really turn around or
not and so they went out to measure this
is by the way this is the hot topic when
I was a graduate student you know
measuring how fast the universe was
decelerating and the deceleration
parameter they probably turned back or
keep on expanding just ever more slowly
yeah yeah and so they wanted to measure
this deceleration parameter and they
would not to measure it and they found
out that the deceleration parameter was
a negative number the universe is not
decelerating at all it's accelerating
its no it the expansion is going faster
and faster it was slowing down so the
beginning was really really rapid
expansion then it's been slowing for a
long time and then something like five
billion years ago it starts speeding up
and that's that's exactly as weird as if
you throw a ball into the air and it
goes up for a few feet sort of slowing
down and then just shoots off in his
face it's the same weirdness like in
terms of this this does not work with
our regular air physics and and so that
was a big mystery when that you know
when that was discovered a lot of people
were not sure if that really works like
what was going on and I mean you were
you were acted in the field of I was
there yeah but but yeah it turned out
you know everything seemed to be fitting
with an accelerating universe and so we
had to figure out how to make the
universe expand faster and it turned out
that that little term that Einstein had
put in in his equations at first it just
keeps the universe stable because he
thought that the universe was not
expanding but there's all these gravity
so you had to have something to kind of
balance that gravity out he put that
what so we put that back to balance the
gravity out and and overcompensate and
push galaxies apart from each other yeah
that causes much will constant or the
vacuum energy or whatever you want to
call it yeah yeah the cosmos we usually
write it as a lambda term and and that's
yeah so that's we're stuck with that now
like we I mean we don't know if it's a
concentrate on theirs there are
different kinds of what we call dark
energy that can do this that can make
the universe expand faster so it may be
that the dark energy is a cosmic Olsson
it may be something that changes over
time in a different kind of way but we
call it dark energy because don't know
what it is we can't see it but it's
making the universe expand faster and
you have a better name for it right yeah
I tried to call it smooth tension yeah
tension is the is a negative pressure
and that's really what it is yeah like
all my great ideas there before their
time yeah yeah your genius is not been
recognized it has trying but so we have
the fact that the universe is
accelerating we can explain it by
imagining this vacuum energy or cause
motion constant smooth tension which has
the property that it's the same amount
of energy in every cubic centimeter even
as the universe expands because you
normally you know like the the density
of something will change as the size of
the boxes thing gets bigger you know you
have a box and you make it twice as big
you have a lower density of whatever was
in the box and dark energy isn't like
that you make the Box twice as big now
you have twice as much dark energy like
that's I mean everything about this
stuff is weird
well let's be specific about the kind of
weirdness yeah it's exactly what the
theory predicts yes right it's just
weird to us to our experience because
we've never encountered a material like
that yeah I mean I I do it rubs me the
wrong way a little bit I think that
people overemphasize the weirdness and
mystery yeah yeah if it's there it just
makes perfect sense yes we understand it
perfectly it's not some ineffable
mystery why it has the value it does is
a mystery but it's not yeah I mean it
matches with the equations I guess when
I when I'm talking about the weirdness I
mean that nothing in our experience on
earth or in any other kind of experiment
does what the Cosmo Duggal constant
that's true yeah and and it is very
similar to physics to throw a ball up in
the air and having it shoot off in his
face for no reason but on a cosmic scale
that's okay because so as in your
opinion as a professional cosmologists
what is the chance what is your Bayesian
credence that the dark energy is a
cosmological constant
is something dynamical uh I mean because
it could also be something that is
almost constant but changing a little
bit yeah yeah I mean you know I I feel
like I feel like the the data fit the
cosmological constant so well and you
know it's hard to like it would
it seems weirder to me that something
would mimic a cosmological constant so
perfectly without actually being it but
you know I I don't know I don't want to
I don't want to put too much money on
any particular thing there but but I I
feel like I go with the cosmic constant
as the default assumption and until I
see some kind of evidence for anything
else I'll just stick with that I vary
between 90 and 95 percent yeah of course
it would be a world shattering discovery
was not so it's very very worth going to
look yeah yeah yeah but it's tough
because there's there's not much we can
measure about it no you know
unfortunately it seems if it is a cosmic
glossa is just a property of space-time
every little bit of space-time has this
little push in it and if you want to
think about it that way and so it's
completely uniform over space it's
utterly invisible all it does is stretch
space and so the only two things you can
measure are the expansion rate of the
universe and the growth of structure in
the universe you know how if galaxies
come together and that's it we don't
know other measurements yeah yeah and
then we've done those measurements so it
looks exactly like Isles of cosmos and
it's like well yeah I mean there are to
be fair some of the alternatives have
laboratory tests you can do where you
might be able to detect something cool
in a lab but if it is a cosmic constant
we're never gonna see any spatial
variations you know everything will look
exactly like you know it's just constant
density forever you know expands the
universe perfectly uniformly and that's
it and we'll just measure that more and
more precisely and the alternatives that
you mention are you know high risk high
gain kinds of things and be really
really important if they were true but
we don't think that they probably are
yeah yeah but they're you know I mean
but there are some big mysteries around
the cosmological constant which I think
are important to talk about it and maybe
not talked about enough
the the size of the cost model constant
the amount of this stuff is inherent in
space-time is weird right because when
you do calculations about how much
vacuum energy there should be in space
so how much the sort of intrinsic energy
in every little bit of space should be
you get a totally different number and
that may be that we are terrible at
those kinds of calculations but but it
seems like there should be it should be
much bigger like the the whatever the
cost moment constant is it should be
much more effective than it is it's just
it right now it's just this little bit
of expansion you know it's currently
dominating the universe because the
universe is getting really big and
everything else is diluting out but it's
it's still like way smaller magnitude in
terms of its effects than we think it
should be based on other kinds of
calculations so when we calculate you
know vacuum energy from quantum field
theory first principles and compare that
number to the cosmological constant
there's a massive disagreement yeah and
that's the mystery is not that there is
a cosmological constant but that it's so
small
without quite being zero right right
right yeah yeah and so I think that's a
really interesting question that maybe
you know maybe the the point is that we
need to better understand you know the
theory and you know how that all fits
together but it's it's it's an it's nice
that there's something that's the that
we have that you know we can say okay
this is this is legitimately strange and
we need to sort it out rather than just
like well this is what we expected it's
there you know and so many people have
been driven to the multiverse and the
entropic principle because of exactly
these reasons their professional
capacity well so so these these
multiverse ideas are I mean there are
lots of different kinds of oversee the
one I guess the one you're talking about
is we have different vacuum vacuum
different sort of regions of space where
the Khaz Modan casa might have different
values so we have our observable
universe that seems really big to us but
it might be a smaller part of some much
larger space where there are other sort
of pockets universe with different
values of the cosmos constant and it may
be that ours is small just because if it
were way too big then you couldn't form
galaxies
so it has to be kind of close to zero
and it doesn't have to be exactly zero
and so we just happen to be in a region
where it's not quite zero but it's you
know sort of conducive to life and
that's the anthropic argument for the
cosmological constant i i've never liked
anthropic arguments i I think that it's
entirely possible that you know that
we'll be forced into into this at some
point that there's no other explanation
that it is just sort of an environmental
effect but but it's never been appealing
to me I think but I want to give you a
percentage a percentage on the
multiverse or a percentage on the cosmo
constant is what it is because of the
anthropic principle useful oh like 50 50
maybe 50 yeah I think that's fair I mean
we know so little right it's just like
if if tomorrow a preprint arrived with a
really killer explanation for why the
cosmos with constant should have exactly
its current value people's belief in the
anthropic principle would plummet yeah
yeah I mean I mean there are some things
that have to be described on topically
like there are some like the fact that
we live on the surface of a planet and
not in deep space or the center of the
Sun that's an anthropic thing right
topic explanation yeah but but
properties of the cosmos itself being
anthropic I and I'm less keen on those
ideas we'll see but yeah okay if the if
the cosmos were constant is the right
answer to the dark energy if it is
something that is not changing as the
universe expands so what does that tell
us about the future what is the future
of the universe whole well like the
standard the sort of standard picture of
of the future of the universe based on
our are sort of concordance cosmology is
this idea that you know we have dark
energy we have dark matter which I guess
we can talk about later and we have
regular matter and the universe started
with a big bang and it's been evolving
ever since that points to a kind of sad
bleak future for the universe so so I'm
meant to judgy about the universe I mean
I mean okay maybe you can find this
inspiring but and basically what happens
is the universe kind of fades to black
in this really long drawn-out way
because what happens is I meant
before the cosmic constant is dominating
the universe because if you have a
universe where everything else dilutes
and this thing doesn't then as the
universe gets bigger it's gonna be more
of higher and higher percentage of the
universe and because every part of the
universe that has cosmos with constant
and it is growing you know it's gonna
make the universe expand faster and
faster and faster and so eventually you
know there will be so much space between
galaxies that we won't be able to see
other galaxies anymore I mean the caveat
is that there's there's one heading
toward us and so that one will hit us
the Andromeda galaxy will collide with
ours in about four billion years and you
know our little local group of galaxies
will kind of coalesce into one big we're
gravitationally bound to each other yeah
the ones that are not bad far away
baseball you throw up into the air yeah
yeah and so in something like a hundred
billion years we won't be able to see
other galaxies anymore because they'll
be so far away and their light will be
so stretched out that we just we won't
be able to pick up any information from
them so extra galactic astronomy will be
over but again 100 billion years hundred
billion years time now yeah yeah so
there's a long time and then and you
know at some point we won't be able to
see the Cosmic Microwave Background
anymore because it'll be too stretched
out by the expansion and and the energy
will be so dilute from the light from
the Cosmic Microwave Background so
people in this very very distant future
will not be able to figure out that the
universe had a beginning and you know
sort of cosmology will be very different
and more limited it'll be a lonely
little island yeah unless we were able
to successfully send em records yeah
yeah yeah but nobody will be able to
check this stuff from first principles
and then then as the universe keeps
expanding since there aren't other
galaxies coming toward us anymore you
don't get all this like new material
thrown into the galaxies so you stop
forming stars you use up all the
hydrogen in our galaxy with making stars
then those stars die and sort of fade
out and then so eventually you have
bunch of black holes and how long it'll
take for the stars to pay down oh it's
many many many hundreds of billions of
years I mean some of these stars are are
very very long-lived so I don't I don't
know
exactly but you know you have many
generations and then they just adventure
ever run out of fuel right yes it's
dollar energy crisis yeah yeah yeah and
then yeah and then you don't make new
stars and then a bunch of things just
start collapsing into black holes and
and those black holes then themselves
start to evaporate so Stephen Hawking
one of the things that he worked out is
that black hole if you leave a black
hole alone long enough it will start to
lose lose mass through particles sort of
quantum leaving yeah I don't I don't
explain without getting into the details
but but yeah so the black holes will
start to evaporate particles will decay
and and will be left in this cold dark
empty universe and that's called the
heat death and that lasts for how long
forever forever I mean that's 50 years
yeah but there is a sense in which at
that point time stops mattering so once
you get to the real heat death I mean
yet this is so we're getting into your
specialty but you know we've reached the
maximum entropy state at the universe so
we get the sort of maximally disordered
universe where all energies just in the
form of waste heat and there's it's very
little you know I mean it's called the
heat death because energy turns into
waste heat but that waste heat is at a
temperature of like 10 to the minus 40
Kelvin or something like it's very
little incredibly energy yeah and and
then you just you have no structure you
have no order and you just have like a
couple of stray photons and that's the
maximum entropy state and if you're at a
maximum increased entropy state you no
longer have an arrow of time okay
nothing is happening in any interesting
sense yeah yeah yeah so we you know we
define time by the direction where
entropy is increasing if entropy can't
increase anymore what even is time and
so well there is time but I think you
said it correctly before it doesn't
matter yeah no arrow of time there's no
difference between one moment in another
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so you just you
have this eternal state of of this cold
dark empty empty universe I used to
think that because of quantum
fluctuations that such a universe would
not be completely quiet there would be
fluctuations in Boltzmann brains and
even Boltzmann's
systems and so forth I now think that
that was a mistake and it was just bad
quantum mechanics I think the correct
statement is if there were an observer
measuring the quantum state at the
universe they would occasionally see
fluctuations in two-brains and so forth
but there's not any observers measuring
anything there's nothing around the
quantum state just sits there quietly
unchanging forever and ever I think that
you're right it's a real heat death
forever that's the most likely one right
of all that we're gonna give our
listeners a menu of options for the
future and do you think this is the most
likely feature I mean I think this this
is this is the one that seems to be you
know best the the most clear
extrapolation from the data you know you
don't have to throw in any new physics
you don't have to extrapolate any of our
current theories beyond the regime where
they make sense so in that sense I think
it's the most clear extrapolation I I'm
not fully convinced by the argument that
there are no fluctuations at that point
and there there's been some really
interesting cool suggestions that you
can have a quantum fluctuation that
creates a new universe so that creates
like just some moment in time from a
current universe in a way that that can
interesting things can happen but you
know that is super speculative we don't
know you know for sure what the best way
to do quantum mechanics in that
environment think you're right there's a
footnote that I should have said in what
I just said which is that if you can
bubble off a completely separate
universe and maybe universe then those
could continue to be created or maybe
we're even the baby of somebody else
that's you yeah yeah I mean I feel like
that's kind of cold comfort because
we're still dead yeah yeah but but like
I still feel like once our observable
universe reaches a heat death like
that's it for our universe you know
maybe some other universe will happen
but it won't be any any in any way
connected to us it'll carry no
information from us you know and so yeah
so it's it's it's nice to think that
there's some kind of rebirth but it has
nothing to do nothing without certainty
there was this old paper by Freeman
Dyson where he claimed that you could
live forever in an eternal universe yeah
so there's a caveat to that though
because his
I just I was just talking with him a
couple weeks ago actually about this
because I'm I've been talking to a bunch
of people about my book yeah and that
only works for a universe that's
linearly expanding it doesn't work for
an accelerating universe and so he was
kind of bummed that his idea doesn't
work anymore because his idea was that
if you are in a universe that's
expanding forever and you keep like
slowing down you're processing and
hibernating and stuff you can
technically live forever
but it was always a cheap just yeah you
know you just recycles more and more
slowly yeah yeah yeah but but I think it
kind of gave him some sense of hope and
now it's like well no so it is weird
it's a weird human quirk right even if
we think that a hundred years from now
we will certainly be dead part of us
doesn't want the universe to die yeah
yeah it's what you're lasting years from
now it's really fascinating and this is
something I'm spending a lot of time
thinking about writing this book because
I you know there's this sense that if
the universe is gonna end at some point
we have no legacy you know there's some
point at which we stop having ever
masters of it all ya know yeah yeah and
and so you have to think about like what
does it mean like what how do you find
meaning in life you know because some
people find meaning in life through the
fact that they're gonna have an impact
on future generations or that they have
children or that they discover something
amazing remove you know humanity forward
or just or just like you're a nice
person and you're like nice things
happen around you and you do some good
in the world like whatever right but if
ultimately you send you know the future
far enough nothing will have like
nothing you do will have ever mattered
you know will ever matter again like
that's a little confronting and then you
have to decide is there a way to assign
meaning to your life that where that
that life and that meaning and all of
your impact disappears you know it's the
Yolo universe you know you only live
once yeah enjoy the moment not very
finite yeah it's a very sort of like you
know Zen kind of thing like you really
have to be in the moment because there's
nothing else that's what you got
all right well thanks Katie let's see if
there's some other possible features of
the universe that are more cheerful
well Morty I mean the thing it doesn't
end well I don't think I'm setting you
up for failure here yeah I mean that's
that's it's never a happy story but but
there are more dramatic ends of the
universe you know so the heat death is
is the sort of standard picture if dark
energy is something other than a
cosmological constant if it's something
that changes over time there's nothing
to say that it doesn't turn around and
go from doing expansion to you know sort
of contracting and if that's the case
then we can end with a big crunch mm-hmm
yeah so that would be where the
expansion would some point stop turning
around and everything would come
together again
and that's a really exciting one because
you know the the galaxies would all get
compressed and like start interacting
each other with each other emerging and
then the then you know everything gets
just more and more dense more and more
crowded and the cool thing about the Big
Crunch as an end of the universe
scenario is that it has this really neat
feature about how the stars died so so
you would think like you have a whole
bunch of galaxies colliding with each
other the stars would collide and you
know blow up or something yeah that's
what you would imagine but actually when
galaxies collide the chance of stars
individually hitting each other is tiny
like even when we're gonna collide with
Andromeda in four billion years the
chance that any single stars like hit
each other in that collision it's
vanishing the space is very big space is
huge yeah and even when galaxies are
coming together space is huge but in a
Big Crunch universe the space is
compressing not just the the matter but
also all of the radiation and so you
know there's this cosmic bank microwave
background floating around from from the
Big Bang that energy will be compressed
again to you know the density the energy
density it was in the early universe and
so we'll start to get to that hot plasma
stage again but even worse in the time
since the Big Bang we've had all these
stars shining so there's all this higher
energy radiation floating around x-rays
and UV and and you know visible light
and that'll start being compressed as
well and so we'll be cooked by this this
radiation background from all the
starlight from all the stars that have
ever shown and then it gets at some
point it gets so compressed that the
surfaces of stars catch fire they have
thermonuclear explosions on the surfaces
of stars as opposed to the middle of the
storm where we now have them yeah yeah
so this so stars will start to be cooked
from the inside out and at that point
like nothing is survived so the Big
Crunch is not just the Big Bang run
backward it yeah no it's more time
reverse yeah yeah it's actually worse
than them then going back to the big the
question is you know is it better to
burn out than fade away right right
either way yeah your goose is cooked
yeah but in the heat death yeah you
slowly slide into oblivion yeah and in
the crunch you get roasted to death and
you burn yeah yeah you can predict you
know when it's gonna happen right like
if the universe were collapsing yeah
through general relativity we could be
able to say exactly how long yes yeah if
we had measured a really high
deceleration parameter we would have a
date you know we would have a number for
for how quickly that's gonna happen and
I feel like that would be kind of a
terrifying concept that's way worse than
he definite in my mind yeah yeah yeah I
mean I guess the one thing that people
find some hope in is that sometimes some
of these Big Crunch models have a bounce
so where there there's a Big Crunch and
then there's a new Big Bang afterward
again not our universe like we're saying
our University balance but we record
yeah yeah exactly yeah I have no way of
sending books through the bounds or CDs
no yeah yeah I mean I can get to it
later there there are some models of a
bouncing universe where you get a little
bit sort of surviving through the bounce
but but this one where you'd have a Big
Crunch is not one of them yeah so
there's the Big Crunch and there's also
another way that dark energy can go
wrong that can that can give you a
different end of the universe which is
something called phantom dark energy so
and and this is theoretically a mess and
I know you don't like it but but I have
my opinions that's yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's it's a cool idea so like
regular a cosmological constant has the
density the same everywhere all the time
in if you have something called phantom
dark energy the density of the dark
energy is increasing over time and what
that does is it means that suddenly the
dark energy is able to not just move
galaxies apart from each other but start
pulling galaxies apart themselves and
ripping stars off galaxies ripping
planets away from their stars and so as
the the density of dark energy increases
increases over time you get to a point
where it rips the entire universe apart
so first first it gets the clusters of
galaxies then the galaxies then the
planets and then you know atoms and then
the whole universe is just rent asunder
that's called the big rip this also
sounds bad yeah this is another one
where it would be terrifying because we
could predict it like we measured a
certain kind of dark energy like we
would we would have a date so so there's
a parameter that we measure for dark
energy now called the equation of state
parameter we call it W and it has to do
with the balance between the pressure
and the density of dark energy and right
now we measure it looks like it's
exactly minus 1 or very very close to it
if it's a little less than minus 1 then
that's phantom dark energy and that
leads to a big rip and once you know the
number what that W is it tells you
exactly how many years you have till the
big rip happens and right now you know
the data are consistent with W equals
minus 1 but the best-fit part of the
data like the number W goes minus 1 is a
constant energy yeah but the best fit
like measurement right now is just a
little bit less than minus 1 well but
the error bars are armed people too much
absolutely yeah no no so but you can
calculate like a maximum like a minimum
amount of time our universe has within
the date of the the errors of the data
and so we know that we have at least 120
billion years and so you know probably
and like as we measure closer and closer
to W equals minus 1 if that's what it
really is that number will get higher
and higher and so you know right now we
have at least hundred 20 billion years
with the next experiments looking for
you know measuring W maybe we'll
to like you know I don't know 500
billion years or whatever so it
presumably if W really is -1 if we
really live in a cosmological constant
universe
we'll just keep pushing that doomsday
farther and farther back yeah but but
it's it's a neat idea that you can you
can calculate it exactly if it's it's
out there now your your objection to fan
of dark energy is that theoretically
it's a mess yeah right
there's like it breaks energy conditions
like it's there's a reason why you
shouldn't have dark energy increasing in
energy density over where all the time
bad things happen in the theory but I
kind of like the idea that you can
extend the parameter space of your model
just a little bit and destroy the
universe and it's worth mentioning that
this idea that as the energy density
increases it rips apart galaxies and
stars and so forth is unique to these
phantom energy models where the energy
is increasing like the cosmos will
constant it doesn't rip galaxies apart
yeah yeah yeah the cosmological constant
only expands really empty space like
wherever there's gravitationally bound
things Cosmo Mikasa is not going to mess
with those basically because there's a
certain amount of dark energy in that
region and your your matter is already
bound in that region there's not going
to be more dark energy in that region
because the energy density doesn't
increase over time if you're a regular
podcast listener then probably like me
you're a fan of audiobooks as well and
audible.com is a wonderful source for
audio books but also audible originals
including documentaries scripted shows
and thinks you can't hear anywhere else
I have fond memories of driving across
the country listening to the Iliad and
the Odyssey on audiobook
but audible.com will bring you all sorts
of genres nonfiction as well as fiction
many of our mindscape guests have books
that also have audiobooks you can get
from audible recently we listen to
Melanie Mitchell talk about artificial
intelligence and her new book is
available on audible but also Michelle
Gelfand
Michael Mann Adam Becker and so forth
all of these wonderful authors have
their books available on audible.com
so as an audible member every month you
choose one audio book regardless of
price as well as
audible originals mindscape listeners
get a special offer you can start
listening with a 30-day audible trial
for free
choose one audiobook in two audible
originals absolutely free visit
audible.com slash mindscape or text
mindscape to 500 500
that's audible.com slash mindscape or
text to the word mindscape 2 5 0 0 - 5 0
0 if you've hinted at this already but
maybe it's worth emphasizing that we're
trying to experimentally distinguish
between these possibilities there's more
possibilities to come but you've laid
out three yeah heat death the crunch the
real collapse or the big rip we're
actually trying to ask which one is
wrong yeah yeah but I mean measuring the
you know how dark energy works is one of
the ways that it's basically the main
way that we can try and distinguish
between these models if we if we figure
out exactly what dark energy has been
doing and and what's doing now we can
extrapolate in the future to decide if
we think it's gonna just keep going the
way it is get stronger or turn around or
you know get weaker and what are the
best ways to do this measurement um well
again dark energy is a tough thing to
measure
so we basically can measure the
expansion history or the growth rate of
structure when we measure the Cosmic
Microwave Background the fluctuations
and this background light we can get
some hints from that as well because it
affects sort of the shapes of the
fluctuations and that that we see from
here so we can get some information that
way and then they're all these you know
experiments like lab expressing
alternative models but mostly it's just
really really carefully measuring how
the universe has been expanding since
you know early times and is it so what
are the biggest experiments they're
going to do this for us um well there's
one called LSST which is a large
synoptic survey telescope it's gonna do
a Sky Survey many times like observe the
same part of sky many times over and
sweep the whole sky you know repeatedly
and that's gonna that's going to give us
a really great survey of galaxies and
things like that surveys that look at
distant supernovae can tell us something
about that because they they can
the expansion rate based on
understanding supernovae figuring out
how far away they are and then learning
something about the expansion that way
that's one of the ways we do it there's
a couple of other telescopes that are
that are sort of specifically aimed at
looking for dark energy stuff dark
energy camera darken to survey these
kinds of things you mentioned
large-scale structure maybe explain a
little bit more how dark energy affects
the large-scale structure yeah so the
the large when I say large-scale
structure I mean like how galaxies and
clusters of galaxies are laid out in the
universe there's this cosmic web where
you get clusters and you get sort of
filaments at work Alexei's lie along
those filaments and then big voids and
if we can measure the how that
large-scale structure is laid out we can
sort of extrapolate how it formed and
how it's been growing over time and and
so that can tell us something about how
dark energy has been influencing this
because you know gravitational collapse
is how galaxies and clusters of galaxies
grow but they're always kind of fighting
against the expansion of the universe
and and as the expansion is getting
faster its preventing more collapse of
structure and and so the shapes of and
so statistics of large-scale structure
can tell us a lot about what's in the
universe and how it's changing over time
so it's like throwing a bunch of
baseballs up in the air and seeing which
one's yeah by the way and which ones
compact apiece yeah yeah it's it's like
yeah it's like if you're trying to I
don't know if you like if you're like
trying to put together a puzzle and
somebody's sort of pulling the the the
table apart while you're doing it you
know you so you can figure out like what
like how by how well you can put
together this puzzle like what's going
on on the table so it certainly sounds
like the dark energy is the important
thing
yeah we're figuring out the future of
these for that stuff that but there's
there are some caveats to that because
there's another model for the end of the
universe that doesn't really have
anything to do with dark energy and
comes out of our understanding particle
physics so there's something that's been
it's been kind of in vogue lately
because of measurements done at the
Large Hadron Collider and this is called
vacuum decay so if
indication what I'm sure everyone has
been waiting for yeah that you indicate
is the coolest part is the absolute best
I mean most interesting way for the
universe end so okay so I'm just gonna
start with the standard model particle
physics the standard model of particle
physics is are sort of our encapsulation
of all of the particles of nature and
the forces of nature as we understand
them through experiments okay so we have
a certain collection of particles we
have quarks and leptons and and we have
these gauge bosons which are force
carriers and so there's there are all
these particles that we understand we've
measured and we know how they work and
that constitutes the standard model
particle physics and the sort of final
piece of that standard model was the
Higgs boson which discovered at the
Large Hadron Collider in 2012 and that
that tells us something about how
particle physics changed in the very
early universe and gave us the sort of
nice happy universe we have today where
we have you know atoms can come together
and form molecules history chemistry and
you know and and yeah and so all of that
works because of what happened with the
Higgs field this sort of field energy
field pervading space in the very early
universe and the Higgs boson is a
excitation of the x field it's a little
a little sort of piece of that Higgs
field that we can break off and examine
its are with our colliders so interested
listeners can buy a book about that that
I wrote so right exactly yeah and so so
when once you have the whole Santa model
of particle physics and the Higgs boson
part of that you can you can start to to
kind of examine how that mechanism
happened and whether it happened in a
way that gave us a really stable
universe or not and so you can you can
kind of chart out based on them the
masses of like the Higgs boson the top
quark where where we lie in this
landscape of stable universes are not
stable universes and when I say stable I
mean a universe where it's pretty much
like
are the the workings of particle physics
are expected to just stay the same
forever forever yeah or you could have
an unstable universe where it would
already have destroyed itself like it
already wouldn't work at all or you can
have what's called a metastable universe
where particle physics is fine for now
but eventually it's all gonna fall apart
and you have to tell us more about what
does it be yeah it's all gonna fall
apart
yeah so what I mean by that is so I have
to say a little bit about the Higgs
field so the Higgs field is this sort of
energy field pervading space and
particles interact with the Higgs field
and that's that kind of determines the
mass of particles okay I'm so like you
know an electron or whatever interaction
the Higgs field interacts with little
pigs feel a little bit so I was a little
bit of mass a quark like you know top
quark or something which is quarks are
constituents of protons and neutrons top
quarks are not part of protons and
neutrons but they're cousins of the ones
that are you know that one interacts
with the IG's field on this slightly
different way I'll have a higher mass
and so there there are so that there's
something about particles interact in
things feel that tells you something
about the masses but the Higgs field
itself can change over time and the
value of these fields sort of the amount
of energy in it has changed since the
very early universe right so it's not
it's just that not just hypothetical
that we think it could you think it
really didn't change these fields I had
a different value earlier yeah yeah and
so that makes field a different value
early on and now it has you know a
certain value that we can kind of
measure and it's possible that there's
another value it could take that would
be somehow energetically favorable so
the way people usually draw this is like
you know you have like a valley and you
have like a ball sitting in a valley and
and that's pretty stable but if that
valley is not really a valley it's just
a little sort of a little sort of divot
in the side of a much deeper valley then
your your little pebble or whatever can
sit in that divot but if something kicks
it a little bit it can fall off and end
up somewhere else in this deeper valley
and that that deeper value would be the
stable state and this little divot
that's higher up is less stable because
it's it's energetically favorable to
like give it a little push and then it
falls down and it lands somewhere else
kind of like if you have you know a cup
of tea right at the edge of a table it's
you know sort of stable but if you tap
it a little bit it's gonna fall down
it's gonna hit the ground and that's
where it's really stable so you want to
put your tea on the on the ground or you
know you don't want to put it right near
the edge of the table and that you're
saying the Higgs field had its current
value for something like 13.8 billion
years but nevertheless it might be
temporary yeah yeah yeah so so it's
possible that you know we're not like
right at the edge of the table our tea
cup is in the middle of the table but
there's still there's still room for it
to fall who's a chance there's a we
could fall often and you know in normal
life if you have a tea cup in the center
of your table you know you're probably
not gonna it's not going to end up on
the floor unless you do something really
dramatic and knock it over
but unfortunately the the universe on
the scale of like fields like the Higgs
field is fundamentally quantum
mechanical and with quantum mechanics
you get quantum tunneling and so we live
in a universe where it's very unlikely
that anything could actually move the
IG's field to this other minimum if that
minimum does exist but if you leave it
alone long enough it could tunnel right
through and end up in the other minimum
it's like if you had if you had a I'm
going through tons of analogies here but
yeah like if you have this pebble in
this divot on this valley you know in
this edge of this valley you know
something could kick it over but but
imagine that like it would take a lot of
energy to kick it over but imagine also
the the edge of that divot is kind of
soft and it could kind of fall through
you know and then and then it'll just
end up rolling all the way down and
ending up at the bottom of the hill and
and and this is you know the face of it
maybe this doesn't sound so bad we don't
we don't know what the Higgs field is
doing in our daily life like what does
it matter what the strength is well it
turns out that if you change the value
of the eggs field you change fundamental
constants of nature in such a way that
atoms don't hold together anymore you
know more chemistry no more no more
chemistry no more yeah everything is is
terrible and then also you know if it
does go to much the Higgs field
to much higher value then in some sense
like everything gets more massive and
then you can have a gravitational
collapse of the entire universe once
that happens that sounds bad yeah yeah
and so it's it's not a good thing so we
don't want to end up in that other
minimum of the higgs field that's that
that's called the true vacuum we
apparently live in a false vacuum so
it's it's called a false vacuum because
it's not like the real vacuum state of
the universe it's not that was you're
all true fun yeah so yeah oh wait you
think so just to be clear yeah now
you're you're saying that not only is it
conceivable that there is another vacuum
state with the higgs field has even
lower energy that it wants to go to but
that we think it's true yeah yeah the
the experiments you know the data point
to the probability that there is another
vacuum that we live in a false vacuum
and and that there's a true vacuum in
you know out there in theory where our
higgs field could quantum tunnel into
the true vacuum and does the tunneling
happen all at once all throughout the
universe how does it no no it's a cool
thing so so it's a very I should say
it's a very low probability event like
any quantum tunneling event you know
it's not likely to happen but if you if
you leave it alone long enough you know
eventually it will but the way it would
work is you know we have Higgs fields
throughout all of space and at any point
in that in the Higgs in this in space
the higgs field could quantum tunnel to
the true vacuum at any moment with a
very low probability and what would
happen is if the higgs field does tunnel
at one point in space then as soon as it
tunnels there it'll kind of knock all of
the higgs field around it into the true
vacuum as well and then there will be so
there will be this expanding bubble of
true vacuum now true vacuum is a space
we cannot live in just be to be very
clear and and as this bubble expands it
has a sort of bubble wall that's this
high-energy sort of shell so that starts
incinerating anything it touches and
then once it passes over something
that's that stuff whatever it passes
over ends up inside the true vacuum
where it can't hold together and maybe
collapses on itself right either
explodes or collapses it's not going to
stick around yeah yeah so that so so
this bubble then expands at likely about
the speed of light or quote very close
speed of light and expanse to the
universe and just destroys absolutely
everything and so because it's happening
at the speed of light because this
public's expanding speed of light you
you absolutely cannot see it coming so
if it if what we're happening you know
if it started on the other side of the
room by the time the light gets to you
from the bubble the bubble is on top of
you and is eating you up so you can't
see coming
fortunately you also wouldn't feel
anything because your nerve impulses do
not travel it was a feat of speed of
light so you you won't have chance to
feel it hit you but it would destroy
absolutely everything and and it could
happen at any moment technically I mean
it's very very unlikely but you know the
Higgs field in this room there could be
a quantum tunneling event right now that
would create this bubble of true vacuum
and just destroy it and we mainly know
that it's unlikely because it hasn't
happened yet right
well we it's because well so it hasn't
happened yet but also we can try and
measure the parameters of the higgs
field in such a way that we can we can
infer that the the tunneling time is
very long and so you know estimates I've
seen give us something like 10 to the
100 or 10 to the 500 years before it's
likely to happen in our observable
universe so you know that suggests that
by the time this is happening we
probably don't care yeah sort of well on
our way to the heat death probably it
doesn't make a big difference but one
thing that I've been working on recently
is there's this there's this calculation
that was done by a few others that
showed that if you have a very small
black hole as its evaporating you can
trigger vacuum decay so it can basically
in a community yeah so a little black
hole as it's evaporating can make the
probability of tunneling and it's in its
vicinity much higher and so if you leave
a black hole alone long enough and let
it evaporate all the way then it can
make vacuum decay happen and concede
that event and we know there are lots of
black holes in our galaxies and
eventually you know as the heat death is
progressing those buckles are going to
stop pulling matter in and start just
evaporating
so so if you calculate the lifetime of
our observable universe based on the
black holes we know about evaporating
we've got only like much less time it's
still something like 10 to the 69 years
and we're not you know fully sure that
that Michaels can do this to the vacuum
we're not even fully sure vacuum decay
can happen and that 10 in 69 years comes
from imagining that we have black holes
the mass of the Sun know about if there
are small black holes yeah yeah and and
one of the one of the things that you
can do with these calculations is you
can show that you know as long as vacuum
decay is possible we we can't have had
little black holes of a certain size
produced during the Big Bang which is
something people talk about sometimes
primordial black holes yeah we don't be
the dark matter sorry they can't be the
dark matter for example yeah I mean
there's caveats on that for the masses
of them and there are certain mass
ranges where it's not fully ruled out
but but really small ones that would
have evaporated by now
might have destroyed the universe so
probably they're not there so literally
at every point in space in this universe
which has a radius of 40 some billion
light years across there's a chance
small one that the Higgs boson field
flips into some larger value there's a
bubble that expands at the speed of
light and will eventually hit us and
we'll all die yeah yeah we hurry that up
not only a few making black holes but at
the Large Hadron Collider are we gonna
figure doom on ourselves no we can't do
it the LHC so so I um I okay so what you
could imagine is if we could make a
little black hole then that thing could
trigger it right but we what we can do
with smashing particles together at the
Large Hadron Collider is way less
powerful than what cosmic rays do in
space all the time and we've measured
cosmic rays you know particles like
nuclei coming from distant galaxies
whatever particles protons at an
jeez so much higher than the Large
Hadron Collider we can't even come close
to creating collisions that that
energetic and so just the fact that
those collisions are happening all the
time in space and have not destroyed us
suggests that like there's really no
possible way that we with our little
smashing of particles here on earth can
do anything even slightly dangerous so
there's no prospect of a dr. Strangelove
Holmes date device no using vacuum decay
no I mean I've tried so I yeah I've been
talking with some colleagues about
possibilities for can you do this on
purpose and it's it's doesn't seem
possible on some watch list did you send
email yeah maybe but but yeah I mean as
far as we know there's no way to make a
little black hole the cosmic rays are
clearly not doing it and I actually have
a paper that I just wrote about with my
colleague Bob Meese about calculating
you know the fact that that cosmic rays
are not making little black holes that
destroy the universe can tell you
something about higher dimensions of
space because it's easier to make black
holes if we have higher dimensions to
space and so the fact that that little
black holes have not been created and
then character your vacuum decay can
tell you something about these extra
dimensions so there's there ways to use
these kinds of things to to think about
new things in physics but you're making
lemonade out of lemons here yeah we are
still here and haven't died to constrain
some parameters of the universe yeah and
it's it's it's fun you know it's it's
fun to to do all these what-if things I
mean you know it may sound like a scary
thing you know the idea that the
universe could have this you know bubble
of quantum death that goes and kills
everything but all of quantum death yeah
the band names yeah but you know it's
still it's still so poorly understood
how all this stuff might work that at
the moment the best we can do is is try
and do some calculations try and get
something cute out of it you know try
and learn something from these kind of
hypothetical you know maybe this will
happen maybe it won't what is that
you know what can we extrapolate from
that I mean then that's that's kind of
one of the main reasons that it's
interesting to think about the end of
the universe because it kind of tells
you something about the assumptions of
your of your physical model and so if
you extrapolate you know let's let's
take what we know and extrapolate it all
the way to the edge of our knowledge
what does that tell us you know that can
either tell us something about the far
future or it can just tell us something
about what we're what kind of
assumptions we're making about our model
and how we can use that to better
understand the physics of today and so
that's kind of fun you know so this idea
that you know we're looking at little
black holes and vacuum decaying cosmic
rays and all this stuff we're really
just taking all the tools we have and
trying to understand a little bit more
about real present-day physics from from
these wild extrapolations which is it's
a fun thing to do so there's even a
silver lining on the cloud of the
complete death of everyone you know and
yeah perspective is I mean and like to
be fair I should say like there's really
no reason to worry about vacuum decay
because first of all it's it's very
unlikely several people you know say
that probably it just means that we
don't understand our theory and you know
the idea that vacuum decay is even
possible is pointing to some kind of
pathology and the theory but also you
know it's you know it's not like like
you wouldn't feel it you wouldn't even
notice it because you wouldn't say oh
yeah nobody would miss you you know
there's no like tragic aftermath I mean
I don't know I I feel like I feel like
there are things that we can worry about
that are much more immediate and that we
have some control over that's true but
but to tie it back to something we said
before in the case of the big rip or the
big crunch we could plausibly imagine
and you could predict exactly when it
was going to happen yeah yeah one of the
features of vacuum decay is you have no
idea no idea though you would not even
know that you'd made a mistake yeah
would you be here you'd be yeah walking
to the grocery store Afghanistan ik ik
that night and then you're going yeah
and that's one of the frustrating things
about is that you don't get to find out
if you're right
like you can do calculations of yeah but
really bad yeah yeah yeah I mean you can
never published right recitation counts
after death the universe yeah
and it's important to remember that the
idea of vacuum decay destroying the
universe there's an old idea this is a
1970s Sidney Coleman and yeah I helped
with this idea but I just want to get
across to myself as well as for the
audience that there's a new piece of
information now not just that well maybe
there are some fields out there that
could decay and that would wipe
everything out but oh no the fields we
know about now have detected could be
responsible for this yeah yeah yeah yeah
and and and there are best measurements
of the Higgs field based on what we've
done with the Large Hadron Collider
really point to this metastability this
this idea that you know the universe is
stable for now but not forever and if
you leave it alone long enough it will
do vacuum decay and we're not sure
because there could be new field right
yeah I mean yeah that's this another
thing that suggests that we shouldn't
worry about this too much is that the
just the whole idea of vacuum decay
depends on the assumption that the
standard model particle physics is the
whole picture and we know it can't be we
know that there's the you know it
doesn't there it doesn't fit well with
you know like general relativity and
like there's we know there's got to be
some something that will replace or
modify the standard model of particle
physics whether it'll modify it in a way
such as the save us from vacuum decay we
don't know but it's very plausible that
something will come up that'll change
our understanding of vacuum decay in a
way that will mean that you know it was
never a worry to begin with but if we
want to just take the standard model
particle physics fully seriously and
extrapolate all the way then this is
this is what the data tell us and the
send of model particle physics has been
very successful you know it's passed
every test so we've thrown at it but
just like general relativity we're
pretty sure it can't be the whole
picture there's got to be something else
I mean I mean dark matter and dark
energy don't fit in the center model of
particle physics yeah therefore there
really has to be something else that is
pretty easily but dark matter is that
well dark energy well I mean if it's if
it's a
pancit then it's not really part of that
question but if it's some kind of
dynamical field it doesn't fit but you
did mention if it is a dynamical field
you mentioned the slightly more hopeful
prospect that we could crunch in some
sense but then be reborn in a few
universe we could bounce instead of just
crunching sure sure yeah and that that's
so there are several ideas they've been
around for a while that involve some
kind of some kind of collapse and and
and bounce there's an idea that was
first described by my PhD advisors Paul
Steinhardt and Neil Turok which is this
idea that maybe in the very early
universe instead of a very rapid
expansion there was some kind of slow
compression happening and and that could
explain some of the same things that we
seem to see in the in the universe and
that compression was was the universe
getting ready to sort of expand again
and and so you can you can have a
universe that expands and then has some
kind of compression and then expands
again and kind of goes in and out and
has this sort of bouncing cyclic cyclic
nature that model is called the aquatic
model and that's been going through
various variations over the years at
first it involves you know two two
parallel universes kind of slamming into
each other and then and then coming
apart and bouncing back and forth like
hands clapping now there's there's a
model that doesn't require extra
dimensions and other universes but has
this sort of similar like you know
compression and expansion the cycle that
goes on so there there are some of those
kinds of models floating around that
that have that have these these cycles
and in some of these models you can have
something kind of surviving through the
cycle so it doesn't go completely
singular where you know you don't go to
fully infinite density and then bounce
off of that you can have a sort of
slower bounce and maybe something
interesting could go through there okay
but again just to just to be clear land
it's not a prospect that will build a
really secure safe now and put some
information and there's a time capsule
to the future yeah I mean it would
basically destroy everything but but you
might have sort of traces of like
fluctuations in the
matter density or something that could
pass through and some something like so
what are the chances that when we look
at the Cosmic Microwave Background
carefully enough will decode signals
from previous universes well it depends
on who yes because there's also this
model by Roger Penrose previous podcast
guests yeah yeah yeah we're we're you
know he's looking for these these
signals in the cosmic background that
that come that would come from a
previous cycle and whether or not
there's been anything seen there is very
controversial most most people say the
you know they're they're weird little
fluctuations they're probably
statistical noise but you know there's
it's possible as we keep examining the
cost microwave background we might see
something that indicates you know some
previous cycle or some kind of
interaction with another kind of
universe there's there's also a model
where you have little bubble universes
that start in through the inflation
process and those bubbles could collide
with each other and we could see a
feature of that in the Cosmic Microwave
Background as well so so you know
although the Cosmic Microwave Background
is really looking at the very early
universe it could tell us something
about the future of the universe through
giving us some insight into how our
universe started and whether that's
compatible with a cyclic kind of model
or even a multiverse kind of model I'm
personally not a fan of any of these
cyclic models just because they make it
impossible to solve the arrow of time
problem there you learn infinite amount
of fine-tuning and the entropy of the
universe infinitely far ago but I could
be wrong about that or maybe the same
format of fine-tuning who knows yeah I
mean these it's it's kind of you know
there are a lot of different ways things
can go right now because there's a lot
that we are sort of still not really
understanding about how physics works in
this very fundamental way you know
because we lack a theory of quantum
gravity and and because there are you
know now these these discussions going
on about maybe space and time aren't
really fundamental and maybe these are
just sort of emerging from you know from
something else
you know something quantum perhaps as
you if you've been talking about you
know maybe
there's the stuff going on that it's so
far out of understanding that you know
all of our assumptions about what should
it you know how universities should and
shouldn't behave are just wrong yeah
welcome for the for the people who are
not professional physicists out there
are their prospects for getting it right
is this just hopelessly philosophical
speculation or do you think we're
actually making progress on these
questions on the question of the future
of the universe the future over the past
you know are there cycles yeah different
thank you yeah so I've been going around
talking to people about this for for a
couple of weeks or a couple months
really about the question of how are we
gonna figure this out how are we gonna
figure out our cosmic model the future
of the universe and there's not really
consensus among the people I've talked
to you know some people are optimistic
you know that that you know we're gonna
we're gonna really figure it out I was I
was just talking with Cooper Johnson
yesterday and he and he was he's history
theorist who's who's worked on his
podcast guess yeah and and he's he's
very optimistic that we're gonna figure
it out but he's optimistic on timescales
of maybe it'll take a hundred years you
know whereas I've talked to some other
people who say like we just have no idea
what's going on
you know our experiments aren't giving
us anything useful our surveys aren't
getting an ascent getting us anything
useful and you know theoretically we're
stuck in the mud so you know I mean I
think there's there's it's we're in an
interesting time right now because all
of our particle physics experiments are
fully consistent with the standard model
of particle physics all of our
measurements of the cosmic you know
evolution are fully consistent with the
concordance cosmology you know dark
matter dark energy expansion big bang
general relativity is passing every test
with flying colors but we know that
those things don't all fit together in a
fully consistent fundamental theory and
so we know there's got to be something
at some point something's got to give
and we don't know what it is and we
don't have any clues really pointing us
in a direction to figure it out and so
maybe we just need more data and as we
get more data we'll start to see where
the cracks lie maybe we need an advance
in
theory and maybe you know better
understanding something like quantum
information will will show us you know
the path to a new theory that'll that'll
tie everything together and and show us
how these pieces fit but at the moment
you know it's kind of all up in the air
which is which is interesting you know
because we have we have these these
models that are so predictive like so
perfectly fitting the data and like we
really understand very well what the
universe is made of how long it's been
around how its evolved over 13.8 billion
years you know we know all that so well
we can calculate everything we can
measure everything but fundamentally
there's something we're missing about
the fundamental nature of reality and
and that's an interesting place to be
yeah as a scientist that's where you
want to be right yeah we would like more
observational experiment with clues we
would like yeah we want to find
something weird that we can't explain
with our current models that would be
nice and so far there's there's not a
whole lot of that yeah out there there
are a couple of weird little anomalies
that may or may not be telling us about
new physics but there's there's nothing
that says like this can't be explained
by our current models therefore we need
to find a model that does explain it we
don't have anything like that other than
the sort of the inconsistencies between
these very successful pictures that work
in different regimes and at a more
personal level not not you as a person
but we as people look you've been
talking about timescales of 10 to 100
years years and on the one hand by the
way I guess I haven't said this out loud
yet but it should to me it seems as if
we should be very puzzled by the fact
that the universe is ten to the ten
years of the past and infinity years or
to the 100 years to the future like we
live in a really really beginning of the
universe by any sensible measure and why
is that is there a good reason for that
I think these are cause multiple
questions of sharing worked sure but the
other is you know does it actually
affect how you go through your life does
it affect how you think about your
existence as a person or your job as a
scientist and you can actually step back
and contemplate the fact that in most of
our sensible extrapolations to the
future
no remnant no bit of information about
your existence will still be anywhere to
be found yeah I mean you know and I I've
I've been thinking about this a lot you
know one of the things that I I asked
when I when I've been interviewing
people about about this for the for the
book one thing one question I asked
everybody is you know how do you feel
about the end of the universe does that
affect your life your philosophy and I
get lots of different answers you know
some people are super depressed about it
some people find the idea of the heat
death super boring and they're desperate
to find something else
some people are totally cool like Zen
like living in the moment whatever it's
great that we don't last forever for me
I think that I I find it a little
troubling the idea that we have no
legacy like I find that a little bit
hard to to think about without feeling
sad but but I also find that having my
head in these clouds all the time but
not you know it's it's not head in the
clouds in terms of something you know
inconsequential like this is real
physics you know this is actual universe
that I'm thinking about so that you know
it's it's removed from me but it's not
it's not imaginary yeah I do find that
there's there's a sense in which it's
kind of comforting like when I think
about like my little problems in my
little life you know the universe is
gonna end like maybe before this grand
proposal deadline yeah yeah so it sort
of does put some things in perspective
you know I mean and even the idea that
we have no legacy ultimately like I
experienced the loss in my family a
little while ago and part of sort of you
know the grieving process I was thinking
about you know that that she's gone and
and you know and that was really sad but
I also thought well we're all gonna go
eventually even the whole universe is
gonna end you know the important thing
is that we make the most of the time we
have you know I you know I spent quality
time with my grandmother well she was
here and now she's gone and and you know
and it's just like in the university and
we can spend quality time with our
universe now and eventually it'll go
away and and and that doesn't mean it's
meaningless you know I think I think
even if it's if it's gone there's still
some meaning that that it was here know
that we were here that that we as
thinking beings figured some stuff out
you know I think that's still a
meaningful and important thing I cannot
even imagine anything to add to that
Katie Mike thanks so much for being on
the podcast thank you for having me
[Music]